come on Bernie John I asked on Twitter
just now what people want me to chat
about today on blog but others and a
bunch of people asked me questions about
college and so then I was like hey you
got college question he said oh my gosh
they did lots of so let's see if I have
any useful wisdom to impart despite the
fact that I haven't been inside of a
classroom in a decade and a half Kate
asks how much plasma would I have to
sell to pay for an engineering degree
first of all if you're gonna get an
engineering degree you should probably
be able to do this calculation yourself
second a lot like way more than you have
you're gonna have to harvest there from
other people which I do not condone but
you're here to solve problems Kurt do I
go to a college fifteen hundred miles
away that I love or one nearer home and
help my parents with my million tiny
siblings so I hope you understand that
we're all assuming you're a Roche person
now do your Roche person it is
commendable that you're so committed to
your family oh I will say a thing here
one of the great benefits of college and
this isn't something everybody wants and
not something everybody gets it's being
able to break off a little bit from the
whole life that has been constructed
around you and then seeing what life is
like when you build some structures for
yourself to kind of see who you are when
you're on your own a little bit but also
family is important and I'm totally
useless so should i major in something
that I'm passionate about or something
that's more financially secure Oh
creepy girl I tell you what uh we don't
know what's gonna be financially secure
at all like what career what skill set
is gonna be useful in the future it's
changing real fast right now it seems to
be kind of a lie that we're telling
ourselves or we're letting colleges tell
us that like that this is a job training
program it's not you are learning how to
be better at stuff and that's gonna be
useful in getting work and in doing work
if you go to college or if you just are
living your life you're gonna acquire a
bunch of skills and you're not gonna
know which ones of those skills are
gonna turn out to be useful have them
precisely because you don't know which
ones are gonna be the ones you need life
is not a job training program we are not
in college we are not on earth to get
jobs what I hope is that we are on earth
to solve problems for ourselves and for
other people an education helps that
whatever kind of education you get
favorite class you took I thought about
this for a long time and I have decided
to say anthropology because it was just
amazing for me at that point in my life
to see how many different ways there are
to be people is it so expensive I made
a whole video about that actually it's
complicated your mom goes to college she
does not but if she did Thomas I would
support her how expensive was it my
school in 1998 the first year I went to
school tuition was $22,000 a year I got
some scholarships and so it was about
$10,000 a year for me today's dollars
that's around 14 grand a year tuition at
Eckerd is now $42,000 a year but 97% of
students get financial aid in what ways
is collage different from say decoupage
or scrapbooking ah it's journalism
dyeing no no no no no suddenly
journalism is having a revival people
are paying for it again I'm a last
question
hey cool decorating ideas well it turns
out we have a back-to-school sale
happening at dftba.com also we've made
up nerdfighter backpack for the first
time ever like it does drives and
nerdfighter crests it's Suttles I
actually designed this and partnership
with spiral which is a company that
makes really cool backpacks we made I
think 500 of them and then there are no
more after that so we'll see how that
goes so got this new hoodie going on
which is super comfy it's got these
things and as for decorations I would
suggest getting a frame like this at
Michael's and getting yourself poster
dftba.com currently on sale because it's
back-to-school time how would a poster
on your wall
totally cool framing it it's like what
who is this classy dude I hope that that
was in some way maybe a little bit
helpful for people John I'll see you on
Tuesday hey also Parade magazine made a
video about me and John and our history
on YouTube you could check it out it's
funny and cute there's a link to that
down in the description as well as to
these things and also to the video that
I made about why college is so expensive